bonjour à toutes et à tous les invités
de ça au caddie ce matin max orville le
président du modem marc du poney
martinique
bonjour max orville bonjour alors max
orville aiguë - christophe castaner
doit-il démissionner suite aux
événements qui se sont déroulés à la
préfecture de police de paris
à mon avis là n'est pas le problème
est ce que c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur qui est responsable des
dysfonctionnements qui sont survenus et
depuis semble-t-il 2015 mais je ne le
pense pas en tout cas je nous ce n'est
pas la réponse que j'attends il ya quand
même des failles
il a reconnu à mais c'est évident qu'il
ya eu des failles il y a aujourd'hui cap
morts dont l'explication n'est pas
claire des dysfonctionnements sur des
choses qu'on savait des choses qu'on
ignorait
bref cette histoire va encore dans les
jours à venir je le crains nous donner
d'autres précisions
comment expliquer l'inexplicable aux
familles il faut trouver un
je suis pas dire le coupable mais
responsable oui vous avez raison c'est
très difficile de pouvoir justifier
l'injustifiable et ne pas comprendre ce
qui s'est passé
pour l'instant l'enquêté en cours et
j'espère qu'elle ne donnera des faits
indubitables est ce que le gouvernement
quelque part ne se défile pas non encore
une fois comme je vous ai dit il semble
d'après les informations que cette
affaire ces dysfonctionnements
apparaissent dès 2015 et en 2015 ce
n'était pas encore le monsieur castaner
le ministre de l'intérieur actuel qui
était au gouvernement alors je sais bien
que lorsqu'on lorsqu'on a une fonction
éminente communiste de l'intérieur on
doit effectivement assumées
mais la véritable question c'est comment
éviter désormais ce type de drame et ses
conséquences désastreuses
parlons des municipales
lors de votre université de rentrée le
parti le modem investi des candidats
alors marques s'y filent à
fort-de-france et vous à schoelcher pas
de listes communes avec dernier le show
mais manette torpille alors sur shell
cherche un seul j'ai renoncé le cher sur
celle cher tout peut arriver je pense
qu'effectivement l'union fait la force
je rappelle que daniel chômé marinette
torpille me soutenait lors des élections
européennes donc je suis convaincue qu'
il peut y avoir consensus d'autant mai
consensus tous derrière moi
non pas du tout et c'est là le modem
investi d'abord parce qu'il faut
rappeler que je suis conseiller
municipal de l'opposition h el cheikh je
suis futur député européen et ayant fait
un score appréciable à celle cher donc
les raisons de main de ma venue sont
tout à fait légitimes
pour autant est-ce que nous pouvons nous
retrouver parce qu'il faut quand même
sortir le sortant comme selon la formule
et bien moi je le crois
donc nous avons des convergences à
affiner à peaufiner et je suis convaincu
qu'on ne pourra pas gagner tout seul
alors pour répondre à votre question je
ne fais pas de la tête de liste une à
motifs pour ne pas y aller ou un motif
pour dire tous derrière moi pas du tout
le modem défend des valeurs humanistes
civique de démocratie participative
2 comment dirais-je de prise en compte
des intérêts des shales chéroy donc j'ai
un message à faire parvenir et a lancé
donc j'appelle le plus grand nombre de
chaînes chéroy à nous rejoindre et ceci
peut se faire très bien avec ceux qui
m'ont soutenu hier les pro européens
en fait vous êtes en train de faire un
appel du pied aussi bien à marine et de
torpilles et à daniel chow mais il ya un
tic à jouer si on veut gagner il ya un
hic âge j'ai toujours pensé
j'ai toujours pensé j'ai toujours dit je
serai présent sur l'élection municipale
de chelles cher même si demain je dois
embrasser d'autres fonctions comme les
fonctions européennes et c'est un atout
pour une ville qui a besoin de fonds
nationaux et de fonds européens et pour
autant jeudi à des gens avec que je
connais bien et avec qui j'ai travaillé
envisageons une union envisageons
quelque chose parce que pour remercier
le maire actuel ne seront pas de trop à
être tous ensemble mais c'est pas un
ticket c'est à dire que si il le
souhaite
y'a pas de problème mais je ne fais pas
de la tête de liste comment dirais-je un
veto c'est pas tous derrière moi alors
marques s'y filent à fort de france
eli chronique à case-pilote tout à fait
qui encore parce que vous avez vous
apporté là ce sont les candidats modem
mais vous apporter aussi votre soutien à
d'autres candidats notamment à saint
joseph
oui à saint joseph mais dans l'attenté
effectivement d'une déclaration de
candidature est officiel je soutiendrai
les personnalités dans marche
éventuelles ça peut être très bien les
10 à beaulieu comme ça peut être manuel
à mon désir
je soutiens christian marche je pense
que de toute façon manuelle à mon désir
en tout cas si elle n'est pas en marche
elle est tout à fait dans la lignée de
elle nous a défendu aux européennes elle
a pris position publiquement vous le
savez et donc qu'il ya des personnalités
qui sans être modem sans être en marche
peuvent répondre à nos critères il ya
rudy du vi le diamant par exemple que
nous soutenons qui m'a soutenu
effectivement aussi pour les élections
européennes et il y en a d'autres que
vous verrez ou robert nous aurons une
candidature pour l'instant c'est la chef
de file jacqueline joue gauche qui mène
les négociations à venir
mais il y en aura d'autres au diamant
robert va y revenir au diamant qui vous
soutenez ce n'est quelques en parodiant
un homard un pardon du soutien aux
marins je sais j'en profite pour
rappeler mon estime et mon affection au
maire actuel de rodolphe désiré et bien
évidemment je soutiens la candidate de
son choix c'est à dire yvonne fritz
d'accord ils vont de trith ski proche du
modem event ritz travaille dans la
continuité de rodolphe désiré qui lui
aussi avait montré son engagement
européen je rappelle que lors de ces
élections le maire du marin nous
soutenait très bien alors une phase par
exemple andré lesueur à rivière salée
est ce que vous allez présenter
présenter un candidat parce que je vois
que vous avez un chef de file frais de
chalon et dans le document que vous
m'avez transmis il est écrit que les
chefs de file ont vocation soit être
tête de liste soit intégré une liste de
rassemblement dans quels cas de figure
nous sommes un soin bien nous sommes
dans sur rivière salée dans le cas d'un
chef de file qui peut entamer des
discussions et des partages un certain
nombre d'idées et à à rivière-salée je
dois le dire andré lesueur à une gestion
tout à fait correct ce qui ne signifie
pas vous le savez qui n'est pas moderne
mais avec qui nous entretenons des
relations cordiales
des contacts sont pris des contacts sont
en cours très bien on a vu les candidats
voyons maintenant votre stratégie qu'est
ce qui vous pousse aujourd'hui à vous
présenter à présenter des candidats vous
le modem sur la martinique alors sur la
martinique pour l'instant le modem à 0
commune
c'est un parti qui a 10 ans c'est un
parti qui rencontre un certain dans
certaines communes un certain un certain
écho et donc nous avons présentée
des candidats motivés responsable et
d'après les résultats obtenus aux
dernières élections européennes nous
avons mis donc effectivement des
candidats c'est le cac à ce pilote salut
c'est le cas sur chaque chaire c'est le
cas notamment sur fort de france pour
venir ou robert vous ne soutenez pas
chantal maignan qui vous a dit que je ne
soutiens pas chantal maignan nous avait
parlé à mme bouchon non j'ai dit madame
joue gondjout bon par les chefs de file
oui je rappelle que madame jugon était
conseillère municipale de l'opposition
sous l'autorité de chantal maignan et si
chantal maignan confirme effectivement
sa candidature c'est une personne qui
est susceptible comment dirais-je avec
laquelle du monde est susceptible de
travailler
comment on aborde une élection quand on
sait que l'on va perdre bien malin qui
peut anticiper sur les résultats des
élections
je rappelle qu'ici aux dernières
européennes que n'entendait pas qui peut
être macro nist ici qu'il peut soutenir
encore macron comment macron peut gagner
en martinique
et comme vous le savez l'histoire a été
malheureusement a du mal à changer
puisque la martinique sur l'outre-mer a
fait gagner la liste de la majorité
présidentielle
donc les jeux ne sont sont rarement fait
mais ce qui peut être intéressant c'est
de savoir un petit peu sur chelle cher
un petit peu pourquoi nous y allons
s'il s'avoue intéressant mais pourquoi
vous y allez allons diffuser aller comme
je voulais dit mais je pensais que vous
aviez déjà répondu ah bon d'accord non
mais bon aujourd'hui nous avons quand
même une majorité qui est de plus en
plus décrié qui dont tous les voyants
sont eux effectivement rouge
il y à des questions très préoccupante
aujourd'hui il y à une scission très
claire est préoccupante en termes de
communication entre le maire et les
agents de la ville il y a des cas de
burn out avancé il y a des comment
comment dirais-je des velléités on
entend des velléités de celui-ci
de mal être au travail et donc rien que
pour cela il convient et je fais un
appel solennel à la majorité au maire de
bien vouloir réunir autour d'une table
tous les protagonistes il le faut de
prendre des médiateurs extérieurs mais
on ne peut pas gouverner sans son
personnel pour mener ses actions de
demain la doctrine ne peut pas être au
nom du peuple pour le peuple
et sans le peuple et c'est un petit peu
ce qu'on voit à chelles cher max orville
je vous remercie bonne journée aller
coûte de nos programmes
merci à vous